you ready oh yeah
it will kill
Jay Nielsen's worst Scythe I'm Trevor
jenkinson I'm 18 years old I like
bladesmithing because it lets me create
something that wouldn't have been in the
world without me Halloween is terrifying
and I'm scared to death this war site is
a menacing variation on a centuries-old
peasants weapon from middle age Europe
ready for battle at a moment's notice
Farmers would take their sides from work
to war during uprisings riots or calls
to battle this weapon uses a long shaft
to generate massive power to cut down
enemies while it's lethal sharp Point
could be thrust into infantry and
Cavalry this multifaceted site features
a fork opposite the blade as a brutal
piercing element and a small blade at
the bottom of the pole to finish off an
opponent scythes are represented in pop
culture as Sinister and ominous weapons
symbolizing death and is most
notoriously wielded by the Grim Reaper
1796 British light Cavalry saber my name
is Boyd Ritter I'm a mechanical engineer
from White Rock New Mexico
at home my son likes to come in and do
the will Willis countdown every time
he's tired of me being in the garage by
myself
I'm really excited about Christmas and
hopefully I get a really good Christmas
present at ten thousand dollars
the 1796 English light Cavalry sword was
first used by British dragoons and
Napoleonic Wars
unlike the suddenly boat French Cavalry
Sabers of the era the English version
had a deep curve whose width increased
as it reached the tip although this
design weakened the Blade's thrusting
capabilities it made every slash heavier
and more brutal
designed to inflict maximum damage
during large melees on the battlefield
the saber had the ability to remove
heads and limbs with a single stroke
the light Cavill Resort is the weapon of
the traditional wooden Christmas
Nutcracker and can be seen at the iconic
soldier's side in the latest film
adaptation of the Tchaikovsky nutcracker
ballet the Nutcracker in the four realms
the war side is kind of weird it's like
a sword that's put on a pickaxe almost
the only steel that I have for a project
this big is 5160 from a leaf spring I
got really excited about the Halloween
episode so I tried to decorate around
the forge a little bit
the power went out this whole challenge
with the war side has been bad luck I'm
really not going to be able to use my
Mill or my grinder or any of that but
I'm going to do as much work as I can
it's gonna be a little bit more
challenging than it would be if the
storm hadn't come through it's kind of
like working in the rainforest right now
I'm about to be going through the Quakes
just hoping everything stays straight I
don't really have enough time to redo
this entire plate again
no warps good deal with the power off I
got all the fortune that I can do done
the power came back on but right now I
just want to get that smaller blade heat
treated to work on the bigger blade and
then get into making the handle
everything looks pretty straight
the next step right now is going to be
Heat Treating the forks and then I'll
finish everything up and make it look
real nice
everything's fitting really well I'm
going to move on to the detail work
the overall plan right now is I'm doing
a Damascus blade out of W-2 and 15 in
20. okay got all my seams closed I'm
gonna bring it up to temperature
I start drawing out my Billet everything
on the power hammer is working excellent
so with the time I have left I'm gonna
get it cut stacked and all welded up
tomorrow I got my steel all blocked up
ready to go
I think I see correct
there's no recovering from that they're
just junk I have to start Plan B we're
starting over
we're gonna go Monastery with the 5160.
the plus side is
my bar is drawn out a lot further than
it was I've lost half my day I've been
messing around with this Damascus not to
mention yesterday we're just gonna go
all out move as fast as we can see if we
can catch up I need to concentrate a lot
on the blade I mean ultimately this is a
really light weapon it needs to stay
alive I do have a lot to get done and a
short amount of time
luckily I have my own personal will
Willis here so at some point today I
will get a countdown and let me know
when all of this is done
I'm gonna put Christmas on this handle I
think it's cool
it's over
good job buddy
our very own dealer of death
the doer of deadly Deeds
the kill test master
Doug markaida
trick or treat trick indeed
thank you
[Music]
all right Trevor the tip alone
penetrates deeply into the gut and the
edges here are sharp enough to well make
it lose his head overall sir it will
kill thank you sir all right point where
you're done here and nice because it's
your turn
I don't know let's see
all right Boyd you nailed the weight
this proves that a light sharp blade is
just as deadly as a heavier sword
overall sir your Nutcracker saber will
kill thanks
all right Smiths welcome to the strength
test a dreaded coffin challenge
[Music]
I'm gonna take the bones and beat them
repeatedly into the blade of your Scythe
hey film Trevor uh pretty good right now
good we'll see how you feel in a minute
laughs
nice job Trevor held up well your Edge
is still good nice and sharp
everything's still tight good job
okay all right boy you ready
I don't know
all right so boy now your Blade's still
sharp it still has a perfect Edge didn't
take any damage that way but
we did pick up a bit of a warp towards
the tip I mean it's definitely
an issue it's not so far out that it
wouldn't cut everything else is still
tight and together good job yes sir all
right bladesmiths this is the sharpest
test the zombie surprise
to test the edge of your weapon I'm
going to take your scythe and cut
through this rope thereby releasing a
surprise all right all right Trevor your
turn so you ready hell yeah
foreign
Trevor The Edge that you have here lends
itself to cut the rope much easier when
you're puncturing it starts to cut all
the way through overall sir it will cut
thank you
all right boy it's your turn are you
ready to do some Christmas tree trimming
keep it all right let's do this
[Music]
all right Boyd so your Edge is sharp and
the weight that you have for this I
didn't have to reset for every cut that
I did I just go up cut up cut up and cut
overall sir
it will cut thanks
forged in fire war of weapons